[Music]
last night oprah winfrey aired an
interview with Ted Turner where he
offered viewers his life lessons and mr.
Turner of course started our Network TBS
which stands for Turner Broadcasting
System he's a pretty big deal in this
nominee well is this true he's in town
yeah this is but he's in town and I'm
being told he just offered to stop by
and say a quick hello so please welcome
the founder of TBS mr. Ted Turner
[Applause]
[Music]
all right now mr Turner as always we are
honored honored to have you here shut up
you androgynous stork the very sight of
you makes my bones bumming I've built
TBS using only a few mr. Belvedere
reruns and the director's cut a [ __ ]
and I'm forced to sit here and watch my
legacy tarnished by some overmedicated
cadaver that's a terrible thing to call
me am i watching you and your waste of a
sidekick
piss of my life's work with this donkey
show makes Teddy junior here beg to be
made into a throw rug all right now
listen Teddy junior of course is your
stuffed aluminum Buffalo on wheels shut
up you ginger training bra
Teddy jr. has been my best friend since
the day Jane Fonda gave birth to him
Jane Fonda did not give birth to Teddy
jr. okay Hale she did it was a natural
water birth in the middle of Lake
Michigan 27 doctors and two tugboats
later we got him out alive and well in
that right Katie jr. okay I'm sorry I
don't think anyone in my audience
believes you I honestly these these
human angel dust vacuums the only thing
they care about is storing the next
Groupon for discount meth then it's off
to use mom and dad's credit card to pay
for sex and an abandoned Blockbuster
Video okay that is just not true
oh yeah when a Blockbuster Video closes
down laws of economics dictate that the
[ __ ] must then move in well anyway was
uh was it was that one of the life
lessons that you shared with Oprah last
night I gave her plenty of life lessons
and maybe this this heard of future
inmates needs you hear a few well yeah I
think so sure yeah okay then Alan put up
the graphic I made standard dammit
you Center that graphic Alan sailer that
graphic there perfect
I'm sorry doesn't look like you put that
much effort into the graphic
first wife listen shut your mouth what
did I just say second life lesson a
radio is hepatitis shouldn't host a talk
show
[Music]
and finally third last lesson
don't let anyone not even the Army Corps
of Engineers tell you a woman can't give
birth to a buffalo in the middle of Lake
Michigan Wow Turner
[Applause]
[Music]
you